wonder woman 1984 is a treat for all
ages but there are many aspects of it
that only adult viewers grasp
from the film's most obscure references
to its uncomfortable moments
these are all the things only adults
notice in wonder woman 1984.
as the title implies wonder woman 1984
picks up with diana in the midst of one
of hollywood's favorite decades to
portray
the 1980s there's a lot to love about
the 80s from the decades awesome music
to its gleaming video stores
and anyone who lived through the 1980s
will recognize many real details
from that time scattered throughout the
set of wonder woman 1984.
sparked by the public's obsession with
fitness people everywhere were darling
spandex and leg warmers
in its earliest shots of people on the
street of dc wonder woman 1984 offers a
number of examples of this look
speaking of fashion no 80s setting would
be complete with ridiculously
over-the-top parachute pants
and a whole lot of metallic fabric steve
trevor shows off a few of these looks
when he and diana attempt to find him an
era appropriate look
even the crosswalk signs in wonder woman
1984 are accurate to the time period
before today's modern leds were
installed in the early 2000s
the signage did indeed display the words
walk don't work
rather than the current symbols
representing a person in mid-stride
wonder woman 1984 gets a whole lot right
about the 1980s but there is still one
important plot detail that it manages to
get
majorly wrong this error can be spotted
at the beginning of max lord's big
finale speech
after successfully taking over the
world's broadcasting signals
using secret government tech lord is
able to splash his face across the
screens of unwitting bystanders
everywhere
no matter where diana turns his face is
visible urging the people of the world
to wish for what they want
and see their wildest dreams come true
the only problem with this super
villainous scheme is that those screens
broadcasting lord's face
include television and computer displays
this scene takes place decades before
the internet or streaming services
became publicly available
in fact the concept of a home computer
was considered incredibly novel and
exotic at the time as apple had just
started selling their first generation
of macintosh computers
that january this sort of
all-encompassing broadcast wasn't just
impossible at the time it was basically
unthinkable
this is a highly sophisticated office
computer
that this blooper wasn't caught by the
production team prior to release it just
goes to show how easy it is
to take technology for granted adults
can't help but roll their eyes on one of
max lord's last business investors
simon stag threatens to report him to
the federal trade commission
if max doesn't return his investment
money within 48 hours
this sort of race against the clock
trope is favored by film and television
producers
because it provides a sense of urgency
to the plot without being too
restrictive
the 48-hour timeline is a particularly
popular choice
you have 48 hours starting at my mark
you have 48 hours to get my money
in 48 hours yeah 20 seconds
you have 48 hours the 1982 action comedy
movie 48 hours starring nick nolte and
eddie murphy
literally calls itself out for using
this cliche in its very title
we can't blame the filmmakers for using
this reliable plot point but it does get
repetitive
younger viewers may find max lord's
conflict engaging
but more mature audiences might find it
to be more than a little bit predictable
the technology max lord uses to take
over the planet's airwaves in wonder
woman 1984
may be the stuff of science fiction but
the parent program mentioned in the
movie as its comparison was actually
entirely real the 1980s marked the
height of the cold war when the united
states and the soviet union were
attempting to one-up each other
while maintaining a public pretense of
peace secret government programs
proliferated during this era
one of which was known as the strategic
defense initiative
or sdi a missile defense system proposed
by ronald reagan in 1983
as an attempt to render nuclear weapons
obsolete
nicknames the star wars program the sti
proposed to utilize
state-of-the-art technology and weapons
like lasers
satellites and ground and space-based
missile systems
to neutralize incoming threats like
nuclear missiles it was officially
scrapped in 1993.
kristen wiig does an excellent job
portraying the painfully shy and
awkward character of barbara minerva who
transforms from an introverted wolf
flower into the empowered apex predator
known as cheetah
however barbara's character arc might
seem remarkably familiar to older
audience members who have seen more
movies
that's because barbara's story revolves
on the axis of a heavily played out
trope
the one where the disregarded nerdy girl
gets a makeover
and suddenly transforms into a popular
hottie just look at my fair lady
grease the princess diaries and she's
all that indeed this plot point has been
seen countless times before
and its use tends to marginalize the
character in question
far more than it empowers them to put it
plainly no one is surprised to see the
ugly duckling become the swan any longer
especially because the duckling is
pretty much always already attractive
okay now take your glasses off let that
hair down and act like you don't know
how pretty you are
in wonder woman 1984 diana unwittingly
uses a cover to dreamstone
to bring her lost love steve trevor back
from the dead but he doesn't return in
the way he'd expect
rather than magically resurrecting his
body the dreamstone inserts steve
trevor's consciousness into the body of
another man
living near diana in washington dc to
minimize audience confusion
the handsome man as he's credited is
shown briefly at the start of his
possession
then his likeness switches to steve
trevors it's possible this was intended
as some sort of metaphor
about only having eyes for your true
love this is something younger audiences
might be able to buy into a little more
easily
but this magical body snatching comes
off as more problematic than romantic
for adults
steve trevor doesn't know who handsome
man is and disrupts his entire life with
his presence
what happens to his job his social life
and all other aspects of his existence
when he suddenly becomes steve wouldn't
the poor man be terrified when suddenly
coming to
after steve forfeits his parasitic
existence also one can't help but wonder
what the implications are of being
intimate with someone's body when they
have no presence of mind to provide
consent
at the very least it's unnerving wonder
woman 1984 is a superhero movie so there
are always going to be some weird
physics involved
these people are superheroes after all
can diana lasso lightning
sure why not but the film is also loaded
with unrealistic depictions of physics
and technology
that are hard to ignore especially for a
jaded adult
for example when steve insists on flying
a modern plane he does so without issue
despite the massive differences between
planes he flew during world war one and
the modern jets he and diana commandeer
the way i fly
it will never find us and when diana
manages to make the jet magically
invisible
it also simultaneously disappears from
radar but just because an object becomes
invisible to the naked eye
doesn't mean it also becomes invisible
to radar because the mass of the plane
is still there to reflect the radar
waves
then again she made the plane invisible
so we can't nitpick this one too much
maybe it's all part of her invisibility
magic but there's also the fact
that at high altitudes it gets pretty
hard to breathe without oxygen
that's a little harder to explain away
for human man steve
put your man back on there's an older
marine i can't breathe
but diana and steve chat away and
assisted as though they're toddling down
the highway
rather than speeding through the air
thousands of feet up at hundreds of
miles an hour
likewise the final battle between wonder
woman and cheetah defies the rules of
electricity to the point of silliness
the two women are impervious to
thousands of volts of electricity
in ways that can only be explained with
comic book logic and again
this is a comic book movie so that's
fair game then suddenly those excuses
stop mattering at all when the live wire
cheetah swings from without any apparent
trouble
contacts the water she's immersed in and
becomes a source of her defeat
professional wrestling is beloved by
people of all ages
but younger fans likely missed a real
life reference planted in the midst of
wonder woman 1984
while visiting the home of a man with
important information regarding the
dream stone
diana examines a magazine lying near his
front door
it's the august 1984 issue of pro
wrestling illustrated
featuring jerry the king lawler on the
front cover as it turns out this
particular
issue really does exist and it really
was in print at the time
this was excitedly pointed out by lola
himself on twitter
after stuart shrek of dc comics brought
it to his attention
it might seem random to feature a pro
wrestling themed magazine in wonder
woman 1984
but at the time sports entertainment had
reached a pinnacle of unparalleled
popularity
the 1980s were a huge decade for
professional wrestling in particular
to the point that it is often referred
to as the sports golden age
offering a nod to this aspect of the
decade is something many grown-up
viewers of wonder woman 1984 no doubt
appreciate
in the dc eu asterio is a celebrated
champion of the amazons who selflessly
sacrificed herself in battle
so the rest of her sisters could flee to
the safety of what would become
themyscira
this fallen hero is remembered as the
golden warrior for her courageous hearts
and legendary armor
to honor asteria a golden statue of her
likeness was erected in themselves
coliseum the amazonian athletic
competition shown in the beginning of
the film
is also held as a way to remember and
reflect upon asterious legacy
in real life asteria was a name given to
several prominent figures in greek
mythology meaning
starry one interestingly this particular
strand of mythology portrays asteria as
eventually transforming into an island
to escape
zeus's advances adult viewers will pick
up on how reminiscent this is of her
origin story
regarding the island of themyscira and
how it echoes yamazan's desires to
separate themselves from the world of
men
culture and technology may have changed
but tales of heroes and villains remain
timeless
considering she fell in battle and was
never heard from again the amazons
naturally assume that asteria died
defending them
this assumption was reinforced when
diana went on a mission to find the
fallen warrior
and was only able to track down
asteria's golden eagle armor
which she winds up using in her final
face-off against cheetah and max lord
however wonder woman 1984's mid-credit
scene
reveals that asteria is very much alive
secretly living among
normal humans and saving the occasional
baby when the opportunity presents
itself
although younger viewers may not
recognize a stunning brunette playing
exterior in the scene
adults undoubtedly will carter made a
name for herself playing diana prince on
the classic wonder woman television
series which originally aired on abc
and cbs from 1975 to 1979
despite the fact that she's been
portraying amazon warriors for quite
some time
carter still manages to dazzle new
viewers in 2020 and beyond
just as she did all the way back in the
70s it will be interesting to see what
dc has plans for the iconic actress
hopefully there's more to come for her
new character beyond this brief if
thrilling appearance
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one